here's a disturbing story from the daily
wire A.I teddy bears could be reading
customized bedtime stories to your kids
within five years this is according to
VTEC Holdings which is a has always been
a kind of higher Tech
toy company
Hong kong-based twine electronics
company they're looking very closely at
the use of AI within toys and they would
equip the toys with a chat GPT style
intelligence they're hoping to do it by
2028 and so what they'll say is you can
incorporate not only the kid's name but
the kids daily activities knows you go
to which school who your friends are it
can actually be telling a story and
talking almost like a good friend the
kids can actually talk to the toy and
the toy can actually give them a
response
I think this is a a very bad idea you'll
be shocked to hear
that I who am rather skeptical of
technological progress and progress
generally I think this is probably a bad
idea
this technology
is designed to
alleviate loneliness
that's the idea of it
because even if you're isolated there
are a lot of lonely people out there
especially in this day and age there are
a lot of people who don't have a lot of
friends maybe they don't feel like they
have any friends in real life and
what they will try to do is turn to
technology to alleviate that loneliness
and so this sort of Technology the the
industry is talking about implementing
it into retirement homes into Hospice
Care into little kids bedrooms where
they're sitting alone at night and now
Mommy and Daddy don't need to read a
story to the kid the teddy bear is just
going to read the story to the kid and
that's going to make the kid feel like
he's talking almost like to a good
friend but
all of the evidence that we have is that
the result is really the opposite
that as technology becomes more
personalized as the media and the
technology become more social people
feel more alienated and more isolated
and the reason for that is we know
that it's just a computer we can tell
the difference between a person and a
computer and I think even if Chachi BT
and AI gets to the point where it is
almost indistinguishable from a human
being we're still going to know we still
know at a deep level the difference
between reality and simulation
we can watch
a conversation on a YouTube video and
that's great and it might pass the time
but it's not really going to make us
feel less lonely
it's not not really going to alleviate
that at all
and and the more that we rely on these
Technologies the the more alienated we
become I mean I've talked to people with
a whole host of Social pathologies and
different conditions
a notable one a notable one of those
conditions we're not allowed to talk
about on YouTube but I think I think we
know which issue we're talking about
here and they will say that they've
fallen into some of these pathologies
because of Technology because they go on
to Tumblr they go on to various social
media networks and they get lost in this
network of virtual friends but they're
not really friends and so all of the
insecurities remain and they just become
exacerbated and they fall further and
further into
fantasy and away from reality not not a
good thing not a good thing for the kid
just read your kid a story you lazy
parent don't don't put a robot teddy
bear in their crib what's wrong with you
right now head on over to
goodranchers.com use promo code nulls as
our great nation's birthday approach as
we are coming together as proud
Americans and savoring the delicious
Taste of homegrown American-made meat
our friends at good Ranchers have the
best Quality Meats you've ever tasted
and they only sell meat that was raised
here in the USA from now until
Independence Day good ranchers will be
offering the best deals to give you
freedom from the meat aisle from rib
eyes New York Scripps all natural
Burgers the most delicious chicken you
could ever want good ranchers has
something for everyone and right now you
get 30 bucks off with our code Knowles
at goodranchers.com this meat is the
best on the market it's just absolutely
phenomenal I I've never seen anything
like it the price is lower than its
competitors and then you're going to get
an additional savings it's unreal I have
people over I want to make sure it's not
just me saying it so I have friends come
over and we and everybody says the same
thing what are you waiting for let the
mouth-watering aroma of American made
meat fill the air bringing Joy unity and
delectable flavors to your celebrations
head on over to goodranchers.com use
code Knowles for 30 bucks off any box
promo code knowlesgoodranchors.com
goodranches.com American Meat delivered
right now go to geniusell.com Knowles
dehydrated skin covered in dark spots
and even puffier bags under the eyes it
could be a problem for all of us all
right and thankfully geniusell has the
answer geniusella's extended your chance
to get their most popular package
featuring beautifully curated skin care
Essentials for life outside in the
Summer sun janya sells a limited time
summer Essentials package includes their
one-of-a-kind Ultra retinol super
moisturizer with a powerful plant
extract a retinol alternative that
delivers results without the harsh side
effects and is perfectly safe to use in
that summer sun you will also get
geniusell's classic skin care therapy
for under eye bags and puffiness that
will get you compliments everywhere you
go plus with its immediate effects
results guaranteed in 12 hours or less
or your money back for one more week
every summer Essentials package includes
their nourishing vitamin C serum for a
visibly clear complexion love the
company
love the founder Coptic Christian from
Egypt who left for the American dream
head on over to geniusell.com Knowles
right now get the summer Essentials
package for over 65 off just for the
summer every subscription order includes
a customized Summer Spot gift box
absolutely free geniusell.com
slash nolds Justice samuelito
one of the greats on the Supreme Court
possibly my very favorite Justice on the
Supreme Court
certainly right up there with Clarence
Thomas and I think probably even I agree
with Alito a little more than I agree
with Thomas
Sam Alito has a big Target on his back
and the libs are going after him so
there's a hack liberal
journalistic Outlet called propublica
which is trying to attack Sam Alito
in Juniper Scandal where there is none
and that's no surprise
the libs have been doing this for years
they've done it to Brett Kavanaugh
they've especially done it to Justice
Thomas
now they're doing it to Sam Alito what's
different here
when when they've done it to
conservative judges in the past the
conservative judges have have gone on
defense
so Brett Kavanaugh mounted that very
strong defense of his confirmation
hearings you know I like beer I still
like beer that whole thing and it worked
and I felt did a pretty good job of
dispelling the
silly nonsense the obviously concocted
nonsense of that woman Christine blasey
Ford where there's no evidence that you
ever even met Brett Kavanaugh you saw
this with uh justice Thomas in the
high-tech lynching confirmation hearings
where Thomas manzas defense he says this
is this is a National Disgrace this is a
circus this is a high-tech lynching for
uppity blacks who in any way Dame to
think for themselves and Joe Biden who
was chairing that meeting immediately
put his head down he thought oh no wait
I can't I look bad now that we're going
after Thomas
in this case though Alito is going on
the offense
Sam Alito published an op-ed a few days
ago in the Wall Street Journal
and says propublica misleads its readers
the publication levels false charges
about Supreme Court recusal Financial
disclosures and a 2008 fishing trip now
the the issue at play here is that some
guy invited Sam Alito to
fly on his private airplane to a place
that they were both going to and
this guy through some indirect means had
business before the court at some point
and so they're saying this is awful and
the leader should have recused himself
in this corruption whatever and Alito
does a very good job of knocking The
Stand he says first of all this issue
has come before the court many times
long before I ever flew in this airplane
and I
My Views haven't really changed on it
and I was invited on this airplane this
was an empty seat it didn't it didn't
incur any extra cost for the guy who did
it to me and uh I I've been totally
above board in all my financial
disclosures and he just he just totally
knocks it down takes the wind out of the
sales the lesson here for conservatives
though
is that this unusual action of going on
offense even before an attack comes out
this needs to become the norm okay we
used to
let things lie a little bit not try to
get too aggressive try to maintain an
above it all sort of approach that's not
going to work any semblance of
neutrality in the public institutions
that's gone you're either you're either
with us or against us you know that's
the place that we're at now I'm not sure
if that was always the case or and and
we're just seeing it more clearly now or
if this is a real change or political
order but whatever it is
we are now engaged in a fairly clearly
defined battle and this laissez-faire
you do you I don't have an opinion
procedural procedurism proceduralism
that has defined our politics for a long
time
that's over I'm so glad you liked that
clip wasn't it great I loved it make
sure you subscribe to the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel make sure you
ring that Bell to get all the other
clips and interviews and games and
episodes